j'ai apporté ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
vous interrogez monsieur premier
ministre sur la position
les positions les divergences les
atermoiements j'avoue que je cherche un
peu mon vocabulaire du gouvernement sur
l'aéroport notre dame des landes
c'est une affaire grave très grave la
cacophonie qui règne dans la majorité
sur la question de l'évacuation des as
10 tu poses vous le savez de nombreuses
questions sur le début des travaux
quand auront ils lieu alors que le
gouvernement est empêtré depuis le début
du quinquennat dans des querelles
internes sur ce projet vous aviez me
semble-t-il sorti du chapeau un
référendum
la belle affaire on pouvait s'interroger
sur sa pertinence à l'époque mais
puisqu'il était là dont acte
mais ce que les français ne comprennent
pas monsieur le ministre c'est la
possibilité de ne pas tenir compte du
résultat
le président de la république peut ne
pas souhaiter que le peuple s'exprime
souhaité qu'ils s'expriment pour ensuite
confié à des journalistes qui ne sait
pas ce qu'il fera
bref on a bien compris que ces derniers
temps ils étaient plus occupés à autre
chose qu'à régler ce problème à bras le
corps mais en tout cas monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez à plusieurs
fois fait entendre votre voix
mais à chaque fois à chaque fois vous
est contredit par votre ministre de
l'écologie madame royal c'est un tournis
incessants la réalité c'est que c'est à
fait dans cette affaire l'autorité de
l'état est affaibli
elle est bafouée la réalité c'est que
dans cette affaire l'état lui même est
pas fou et les querelles internes au
gouvernement conduisent à une situation
de blocage la réalité enfin c'est que le
peuple
la parole du peuple est bafouée et ça
c'est inacceptable
alors monsieur le premier ministre en
attendant que ça change ça va sans doute
changer
quelle est la position du gouvernement
dans cette affaire dans la sphère notre
dame des landes et pour reprendre les
termes de votre ministre vous allez
arrêter les frais ou pas je résume
stop ou encore la parole est à monsieur
le premier ministre manuel valls
ce président là faisait messieurs les
députés monsieur philippe gosselin nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion souvent à
travers les différentes questions des
parlementaires de la majorité comme de
l'opposition de cette grande région
aussi d'évoquer ce sujet c'est un
dossier complexe qui dure depuis déjà
plusieurs années mais mais à chaque
étape administrative à chaque recours
administratif ce dossier avance et les
élus la plupart d'entre eux de
loire-atlantique des pays de la loire où
la bretagne région qui sont directement
concernés
les chambres de commerce les acteurs
économiques soutiennent ce projet il a
été décidé
le présent république l'avait annoncé
une consultation pour donner encore plus
de force à ce projet
et contrairement d'ailleurs à tous les
pronostics il ya une majorité
d'électeurs des pays de la loire qui se
sont de la loire atlantique qui se sont
déplacés et une très nette majorité qui
s'est prononcé en faveur de ce projet
pas de n'importe quel projet d'un projet
en toute connaissance de cause
c'est à dire le transfert de l'actuel
aéroport à notre dame des landes le
projet 8 même après un débat auquel ont
participé les citoyens et avec toutes
les informations qui ont été données à
l'ensemble des électeurs
et moi je crois comme chacun d'entre
vous à la force
en effet du peuple et quand le peuple se
prononce après que toutes les procédures
de droit et l'état de droit ont été
respectées
la décision elle doit s'appliquer
c'est ma conception et je ne doute pas
un seul instant
c'est la conception de tous les
parlementaires qui sont ici au delà des
positions qui sont prises par les uns et
par les larmes aux yeux gris cède seule
position qui puisse aujourd'hui valoir
le respect des procédures de l'état de
droit et le respect de la parole du
peuple et de la démocratie
il y a un calendrier ne sert à rien de
s'énerver il y a un calendrier qui doit
être respecté et l'évacuation de la zad
de notre dame des landes de la zad
actuel de notre dame des landes comme la
protection d'ailleurs du centre ville de
nantes
trop souvent saccagés par des casseurs
qui ne respecte pas ni l'état de droit
ni la démocratie sont pour nous
évidemment des priorités
donc le calendrier sera respecté
évacuation pour que les travaux de
préparation puis ce faire et pour que
les travaux pour cette nouvelle
aéroports puisse se faire j'entends tout
l'écrit jean durand leurs comptes at-il
d'interruption j'entends ici ou là les
commentaires mais ce qui - m'importe
c'est l'engagement qui est celui du
gouvernement et le respect de cette
parole de l'est il faut être cependant
et la ministe d'ailleurs de l'écologie a
raison de ce point de vue là de le
signaler et ceux qui connaissent le
dossier le savent bien et à commencer
par le ministre de l'intérieur
nous savons que cette opération
d'évacuation sera périlleuse et risquée
et est d'abord par les forces de l'ordre
mais signe à violence elle ne vient pas
de l'état la seule violence qui viennent
elle est aujourd'hui de ces groupes à 10
donc raison de plus pour ne pas céder à
la violence
raison de plus comme le fait sur chacun
des dossiers
le ministre de l'intérieur réparer cela
avec précision et miccoli cité
raison de plus pour ne pas apporter des
paroles qui perturbe l'action
de l'état pour moi j'en prends
l'engagement ici devant le parlement
parce que c'est ma conception de l'état
de droit c'est ma conception de la
république
c'est ma conception de la démocratie
c'est ma conception de la responsabilité
cet aéroport non seulement se fera parce
que les électeurs le demande mais parce
que c'est ainsi qu'on regarde l'avenir
en face c'est ainsi qu'on respecte les
français merci monsieur le premier
ministre l'a pas